[Music]
okay everybody i am so excited today
because i am joined by the one and only
dove cameron aka ellen wright and
bignate which is coming to paramount
plus
next thursday dove how are you doing
today i'm actually really really well
how are you
good that's great to hear and um i'm
really excited about this show coming
out i'm a huge fan of all of your work
and this just continues that so i was
curious while watching it are you
reading straight from a script when
you're doing something like voiceover or
you want someone who wants to like
memorize it
oh no reading from the script i mean
listen i
we go line by line in voiceover
so
it's really i i feel it's like
i feel like it'll be really really hard
to do
based on just memorization alone
especially because i feel like
when you're reading it with a producer
or another voice actor
a lot of big nade funny enough and not
every not every production is the same
in this way
but a lot of big nate um is very improv
heavy and it took me kind of a while to
get into that like after the first
couple episodes of me being like
i'm a fish out of water like because all
these people this is like what they do
and they're so funny and it's so
intimidating to watch them do it i was
like
no way no way why am i here um
and then as i got more
comfortable like back in 2020 when i was
like doing this on my laptop because
everything was closed and the pandemic
had just begun
i was trying to like be like tech
support and like
it was so funny like seeing me with my
like silly little like microphone and
like sitting on my floor with like
pillows around trying to create like a
sound booth and all these people have
sound boobs in their homes because they
are recording artists first right and i
was like on hollywood boulevard being
like sorry guys um
yeah i was really really unprofessional
um but i it took me a while to realize
that like
this is actually an opportunity
you kind of turn into like a stand-up
comic like the goal is to make the
producers
laugh um and like
you know improvise and
um go wild make make insane sounds like
you're trying to do a child again and
like making your parents laugh by like
doing like silly tricks with like when
the family comes over and um
and that's like that's something that
this experience like really
kind of taught me was to actually to be
less
like militant with like i'm gonna
memorize and go in it's like it's like
an improv class it's really fun
yeah and i love that comparison to
stand-up you just made and it's
interesting because yeah i never thought
of it like that where it is more
creating in your head too of what you're
gonna say that's pretty cool so was
there any characters
from other anime shows that helped like
maybe inspire portrayal of how you're
gonna approach ellen wright here
i think there were in the beginning like
i think i actually went in with a sort
of like uh um i always loved candace
from phineas and ferb
that like that
like i always thought i always thought
that that
ashley tisdale um
was really funny in that and also this
is the older sister is like almost
always the straight man right
she's almost always kind of the one
who's like you're a brat and that's it
uh and so
i went in kind of not allowing myself to
be
as wild and uh
unhinged as i cut my character becomes
throughout the series um i don't think
that the older sister in uh
um rick and morty you know like i was
kind of thinking about like that kind of
thing but then
ellen just developed into her own
thing i think she sounds more like me as
the series goes on because i stopped
trying to make her into something and
then we just it became something else so
yeah yeah sure no and that's that's
awesome that that you get to shine
through that character too because i
think that's just huge for people want
to watch this because of you now was
there any favorite animated shows for
you growing up as a kid is there
something that's like your cup of tea
you know i um i i i've said this um
just before but i
i didn't have cable um so
and like we didn't have like we had like
the rabbit ears
um so we had i think four channels and
one of them mostly showed news uh and
then there was another one that was like
you know upn 11 at the time which turned
into like cw i think which had like
seinfeld uh so i didn't write and had
like seinfeld and like america's next
top model and like um sometimes the
simpsons
i think maybe uh maybe i'm being crazy
about that someone's gonna be like
that's wrong no that sounds right i
think so right yeah yeah but i so we
didn't the only cartoons that i ever saw
were at friends houses who had cable
um and then we had like a third i swear
i swear we had like a
vh that 32-hour
sounds crazy because i'm like no way of
vhs could carry that much cartoonish but
i think it did it was like 32 hours of
straight might have been two like a two
special thing of straight
uh looney tunes
so i grew up watching
those and then my family got weirdly
into like family guy and we would get
dvds of that for christmas but it was
like
very few and far between and i remember
hey arnold being like mecca it was like
right because hey arnold and like
rugrats like those were the ones and so
that's something that i actually really
love about big nate is
as the series was going and i was able
to see
the animation
and like speak to the producers about it
i was like this is really nostalgic and
really like reminiscent of
the kind of like older style of cartoons
and writing um and it doesn't feel aimed
as much or like curated as much towards
an audience as i feel like a lot of
children's content is these days so
i definitely feel very like
happy to be a part of something that
feels so um
yeah just like tried and true like a
classic like a modern classic
yeah and it's cool you mentioned that
because like with modern classics and
older animation like you're also going
the other direction where you're going
to be in the live power puff series are
you excited about that playing bubbles
like is that something that's kind of
like a dream come true for you oh yeah i
mean come on
bubbles like first of all powerpuff
girls i saw the movie when it came out
when i was a kid again no cable um and i
remember like
apparently my mom just sent me a
like a kodak
photo of my birthday party where i was
had pigtails powerpuff girls like little
party hat and a powerpuff girls t-shirt
i have no recollection of this but i was
a massive powerpuff girls fan growing up
and i was always bubbles because i was
blonde
um and i thought she was the cutest and
so when i heard that diablo cody one of
my all-time favorite like cult classic
writers um was writing it and i read the
script i was like this is
unhinged this is insane conceptually um
and i want to be part of it and we shot
the pilot
um and it's a very interesting process
because
very rarely do you make a pilot that is
so
hype like highly watched like everybody
was kind of
um already from the beginning being very
like all right like what's let's see
what this is about kind of thing like
very rarely is there a property that is
so beloved um
but coming from someone who was one of
the people who loved it so much
um
i really i really think they did it
justice they really like
gave the kind of credence and honor and
like
um
you know just like the the respect that
it deserved as we were making it
but i think that what people don't
realize is that a lot of the time people
will like i think this happened with
game of thrones they made a pilot
spent all this money on it and then it
like wasn't quite right and they were
like well why are we gonna start the
show
with elements that we're then gonna have
to backtrack and change we should just
like do it right from the beginning so
that's kind of where we're at right now
with that um is we're just like figuring
out all the things that we want to make
it perfect and dreamy and then we'll go
back in and release the show that we
want to do
yeah and i can't wait to see what you do
with the character it's so exciting and
just also when i watch this big nate
screeners i love seeing that i am
excited to see dove camera do something
because i'm expecting a little bit of
singing even in your acting work and we
get a little bit here and what i really
loved was your performance as betsy and
shmigadoon this year i i loved it so
what i do want to know though i always
wonder when i see this
what is the main love for you because we
know you have such a great singing
career too is it acting or is it singing
or is it you know kind of like a tie for
you
it's definitely a tie for me i was
reading something the other day that
kind of helped me finally answer that
question
i was reading about
madonna actually
um who i'm a huge fan of and she wrote
like in her early career when people
were coming and seeing her like kind of
black box shows
um
she was like i'm i i can sing i am a
dancer but overall don't think of me as
those things like think of me as a
performance artist
and i read that and i was like
is that what it is because it's really
like
i've never been the person i've always
struggled to answer this question
because
i enjoy acting like even just the act of
like auditioning i'll leave and be like
that was such a fun day and i don't care
what happens you know like i really like
the actual act of it um i've really come
to love voice over i wouldn't i enjoy
singing if it's the right thing it's not
like a feeling kind of thing it's like
the music has to take me um and i love
songwriting and it's like all of these
things kind of
fuse to be like one emotion for me so
it's like
it's just about like the kind of um
i don't know i feel lucky that like my
career kind of aids all of them but but
they do all feel like one thing so it's
really hard for me to answer
no it's still a great answer and
everybody you get to check her out do
all of this voice acting acting singing
you name it in big nate as ellen wright
on paramount plus next thursday dove
thank you so much for joining me today
i'll talk to you in the future one day
thank you so much have a good day